es un fin de semana de asesinatos a
consecuencia de la guerra entre bandas
del narcotráfico aseguró la Policía
Nacional la noche del sábado nuevo
ataque armado ocurrió en un suburbio de
la ciudad de Guayaquil con un saldo que
ya supera la Decena de personas según
anunció la fiscalía general del estado
Guayaquil es el centro de la disputas
entre las bandas del narcotráfico según
la Policía Nacional un grupo de personas
atacó con fusiles a otros que se
encontraban reunidos en un taller
mecánico cinco de los fallecidos tenían
antecedentes penales y una de las
víctimas registraba seis detenciones por
robo el crimen múltiple ocurrió mientras
la ciudad de Guayaquil se encuentra en
medio de un estado de sección y el
gobierno había anunciado medidas contra
la criminalidad hace cuatro días
paralelamente otro ataque armado ocurrió
en la ciudad costera de atacames
siguiendo el mismo patrón según anunció
la Policía Nacional un grupo fuertemente
armado ingresó en un lugar de diversión
nocturna abriendo fuego en contra de los
asistentes las autoridades
responsabilizan de lo sucedido a las
luchas por territorio entre las bandas
del crimen organizado señalando a los
gánster y a los tiburones bandas
delincuencia organizada en este país
sucede cuando el Consejo de Seguridad
Pública del Estado ha recomendado al
gobierno utilizar armas letales y
aplicar nuevas medidas fuertes contra la
criminalidad y declarar al terrorismo
como amenaza y enfrentar a los grupos
delincuencia organizada por parte de las
fuerzas armadas